[Musique]
bonjour frédéric bhérer bonjour monsieur
alain livory bonjour tous les auditeurs
dit rice de martinique 1ère vous êtes le
premier secrétaire de la fédération
socialiste de la martinique le ps et
m'offre d'eric guéret alors vous bien
entendu votre confrère tout à leur dire
que vous allez vous entretenir avec moi
mais vous commencez par une attaque
manuel valls s'est dit c'est pas un
entretien si manuel valls vous vous me
parlez de mort du ps avant de vous
parler du ps je voudrais adresser mon
soutien à l'équipe de basket de la
gauloise 1,1 par rapport à jeudi un
exploit donc déjà en campagne
ils ont tous un bon on vise à se
comporter comme ça rappelez vous que je
suis comme les membres de la gauloise
donc je referme la parenthèse et pour
répondre à votre question parce que faut
pas que je me défile vous parler de deux
mots du ps quand je vous dise que le ps
est résilient le ps ne meurt pas comme
ça nous en avons connu d'autres défaites
oui manuel valls a ses limites les lions
je vais partir
enfin commencer par le début appelez
vous qu'en 1993 nous avons connu une
lourde défaite
nous avons eu
52 10 57 exactement dans l'assemblée
quatre ans après nous gagnons résiste
hâtif avec une forte majorité
et puis je peux vous parler d'autre
scénario que nous avons eue à vivre
encore le parti socialiste est un parti
séculaire c'est un parti qui est né et
qui a commencé par les sefyu vieux parti
aujourd'hui
non c'est un parti séculaire est pas un
vieux parti
voyez la différence ça veut dire que
nous avons traversé le temps dans
travers les époques nous sommes là
depuis 1905 avec la sq la création de
l'ess filles ou les filles qui a laissé
place au ps en 1969
et puis en 1971 parce qu'il faut le
rappeler ça aussi c'est important pour
nous jeunes militants au congrès
d'epinay
on a connu l'unification des socialistes
de françois mitterrand et puis la suite
vous la connaissez donc est ce que nous
sommes en et bien je vous dirais que
depuis plus de dix ans tous les six mois
on nous donne comme d'accord depuis le
congrès d'epinay le ps a pu se réformer
il ya eu des réformes
peut-être qu'il y en a d'autres à faire
je voulais je vous le concept est ce
qu'il faut exclure manuel valls
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr et vous avez
entendu que notre premier secrétaire
national l'a clairement dit mais à un
moment il faut arrêter avec ça peut-être
eût-il fallu pas de décision beaucoup
plus tôt de trois femmes politiques
martine aubry anne hidalgo
christiane taubira des intellectuels des
artisans quillan ce mouvement
qu'ils ont intitulé dès demain et benoît
hamon qui lui valent aussi lancé son
mouvement trans partisan en juillet il
vous me dites que le ps n'est pas
moribond tout à l'heure c'est un mot
maintenant ces mots eu beau tout à
l'heure vous allez encore les dieux les
choses on y arrivera maintenant je vous
répondrai que ce n'est pas parce que
quelques militants fait style de
militants comme on dit des élites entre
guillemets porte et accueillant un
mouvement qu'on dit que le parti est
d'ailleurs ne cite pas le parti on a
l'impression que chaque personne fait à
sa sauce au sein du parti que chaque
personne fait sa petite cuisine sans
chercher à rassembler c'est un mal bien
français derrière la po qui pour vous
chez vous si c'est le cas français c'est
un mal français ne le retrouve pas au
tout un problème y compris dans la vie
associative malheureusement alors
maintenant ils font leur le mouvement
pourquoi pas je dis que c'est dommage on
pourrait effectivement comme vous le
dites si bien nous laver le linge sale
en famille c'est par là qu'il faut
commencer
regardez peut-être faire de véritables
assises du gardien j'appelle ça de mes
voeux de plusieurs modes d'ailleurs
regardez ce qui ne va pas et puis il
vaut médiers pu repartir que ceux
derrière un premier secrétaire ou avec
plutôt entre pour reprendre les termes
de l'un de mes jeunes militants ici pas
derrière mais avec notre premier
secrétaire nationale que se gonfle est
avec lui pour effectivement faire aller
de l'avant le parti n'en a l'impression
qu'il n'y a pas de chef
quand même de la partie malgré un
premier ce critère équivalent à l'aller
survie qui complètement inaudible
on a l'impression que sur le bateau à la
dérive qui a pas vraiment de chiffres
qui a pas de voix forte de personnalités
fortes
ici lève qui voilà ça c'est votre
lecture monsieur legault et quand vous
êtes menés secrétariat trop de chefs
alors quand vous apprenez ce que donne
aussi grand parti et vous avez avec vous
de très fortes personnalités vous
conjuguez avec vous mais vous n'éliminer
pas les uns les autres parce qu'ils ont
une forte personnalité
vous travaillez vous avancez avec
malheureusement quand on travaille comme
ça on vous dit que vous fait la synthèse
mort on vous dit que vous ne vous
comportez pas un chef pour être un chef
faut-il être un dictateur oui mais il
faut parfois savoir taper du poing sur
la table un certain moment il faut le
faire je vous je l'admets je vous
concède slaoui un certain moment il faut
le faire il l'a fait il l'a fait il l'a
fait peut-être un peu tardivement et
peut-être pas assez fort ce que le
président longue peut-être la voix forte
du ps aujourd'hui ainsi que dimanche
après la passation de pouvoir il se
rendra rue solférino siège du parti
oui parce que là il ne sera plus
président et ou de vie souhaité qu'il
devra pire elle même partie alors je ne
suis pas venu ici pour vous dire qui je
souhaite à la tête du parti
je vous répondais que françois est resté
quand même dix ans à la tête du ps et il
a fait un excellent boulot je vous
réponds dit aussi qu'il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui peuvent remplir cette
fonction vraiment honorablement mais
plus qu'honorablement je vois quelqu'un
comme notre premier ministre c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui est très tempéré qui
a l'envergure qu'il faut mais ceci dit
ne m'a pas donné deux messages ans aussi
je vous puisque vous me posez la
question je vous pourrez vous et gones
et un certain nombre d'hommes et de
femmes qui pourraient remplir cette fois
qu'il veut non législative vous n'avez
qu'un seul candidat estampillé ps
raphaël vaugirard dans le centre est ce
qu'il aura le soutien de la ville de
trinity
200 atantique alors quand vous entendez
quand vous dites soutien de la ville de
tiznit et je rajoute que de la dignité
vous parlez de qui la jugulaire de le
reste du maire devant ben faleh kouici
le maire a clairement dit est bon et
c'est plutôt lui qu'il faut poser cette
question d'ailleurs bon mais comme ces
publics
je peux me répondre le met a clairement
dit qu'il soutient malin madame manon il
est clair là dessus il a fait son choix
maintenant nous avons un candidat
socialiste nous l'avons dit très tôt
d'ailleurs nous sommes en sortant d'un
simple martinique nouvelle nous avons
dit que nous avons vocation à présenter
des candidats et que nous présentons des
candidats ne veut même pas présenter des
candidats nous en avons présenté un
et puis que je vous dise monsieur le la
fédération socialiste
c'est ce taux est pour nous nous avons
tous joué candidats de cette
circonscription
oui même si elle a été vous avez même eu
des idées
nous avons même désirer alors je ne vois
pas pourquoi on va s'effacer au profit
d'un d'untel ou d'untel d'accord
le maire de trinité ce sera il faut on
vous en êtes avec lui il faut qu'il
choisisse son camp
définitivement est-ce qu'il est d'être
exclu du parti
alors faut parler du maire de trinité
vous ne parlez pas de défilé devant le
premier secrétaire de la fsc martin joue
pas les fesses de vous parler de
football ou du mais vrai palais du maire
je vous dis que le maire fait son
travail à la trinité il travaille j'ai
très bien d'ailleurs et je suis dans son
équipe nous travaillons très bien mais
vraiment très bien ensemble pour ça
qu'il s'agit de la fédération c'est
autre chose
il a pris ses distances il n'a pas
démissionné de la fédération il l'a
il s'est mis en congé bien entendu c'est
vrai je le lui ai déjà dit d'ailleurs il
la ville à vivre un moment il faudra
qu'ils soient plus claires bon mais ça
je le veux lui laisse le soin de dire ce
qu'il fera d'accord est-ce qu'il faut
aussi repenser une refondation du de la
fsm qu'on parti qui ait ce qui a eu des
illustres représentants
en martinique n'est plus capable de
présenter quatre candidats sur les
circonscriptions sur les 4,6 secondes on
est obligé d'attendre ou bien de
discuter avec le ppm alors je vous
entendu parlé de discussions avec le pp
quelque chose moi je ne suis dans aucune
discussion avec le ppm à l'eau si
quelque chose que j'ignore il faut de me
le dire maintenant nous ne sommes pas
capables de présenter quatre candidats
je ne le dirai pas ainsi nous avons fait
le choix de présenter un candidat et de
métro nous faust nos forces de rien
notre candidat pour le faire élire
voilà la véritable formulation frédéric
bhérer je vous remercie passé une
excellente journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes
c'est moi qui vous remercie c'est
toujours trop court quand on vient ici
[Musique]